madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce mercredi 26
décembre au Tchad de 8 ans de travaux
forcés pour les 6 français de l'Arche de
Zoé les familles espèrent un transfert
rapide des condamné vers la France que
Paris devrait demander à la justice
tchadienne dans les plus brefs délais
l'est de la France sous la neige et la
pluie verglassante ces intempéries ont
causé une cinquantaine d'accidents de
voiture et perturbé la circulation des
trains Météo France ainsi de chacun à la
prudence
cérémonie du souvenir en Indonésie en
Thaïlande au Sri Lanka et en Inde 3 ans
après le tsunami qui est causait la mort
d'au moins 220 000 personnes les
populations vivent toujours dans le
dénuement
les Français dépensent de plus en plus
d'argent pour se loger c'est dans les
familles les moins fortunés que le poids
du loyer et le plus lourd près de 25% du
budget
la Slovénie ancien pays de l'Union
soviétique est devenu la destination
tendance avec des paysages exceptionnels
des équipements de ski de qualité et des
prix attractifs
et puis Laurent Gerra nous parlera de
son nouveau spectacle la suite du
précédent ont cette fois il flingue
comme il dit en musique avec des
nouvelles voies et des invités surprises
il est au Palais des Congrès jusqu'au 31
décembre et dans ce journal dans
quelques instants
les bénévoles de l'Arche de Zoé ont
accusé le coup à la lecture du verdict 8
ans de travaux forcés pour chacun des 6
membres de l'association cet après-midi
pour la première fois Éric Breteau le
leader du groupe avait exprimé quelques
regrets en se disant désolé pour les
enfants de Chadia sur place Amaury
Gibert et Frédéric grange
c'est peut-être la seule surprise de ce
procès près de trois heures de délibéré
une longue attente pour les membres de
l'Arche de Zoé restés dans le box comme
prostré le visage grave
à 18h30 la cour criminelle fait son
entrée le président rassemble les
accusés à la barre et non ce verdict les
six Français sont tous reconnus
coupables dans l'élèvement de mineurs
tous condamnés à 8 ans travaux forcés on
aurait pu ne pas plaider on a pu rien
faire on m'a sentiment
collectivement la même peine même
dommage intérêt c'est une
décision c'est insupportable dans leur
plaidoiries les avocats de la défense
avaient pourtant tenté le tout pour le
tout ce ne sont pas des négriers à
lancer l'un d'entre eux Eric Breteau un
cœur immense ajouté un autre le
président de l'Arche de Zoé qui a pris
une dernière fois la parole si ses
enfants ou si une partie de ces enfants
sont tchadiens parce qu'on nous a menti
en nous présentant des enfants de Chadia
comme des enfants soudanais et qu'on a
séparé des familles c'est un drame dont
nous sommes vraiment navrés et désolé
car notre intention n'a jamais été de
séparer les familles les excuses qui n'y
changeront rien
également toucher la partie adverse
quelques applaudissements ont accompagné
le verdict
on a dépassé le stade de la traite
négrière on en est plus là donc
mon impression ce n'est que une
impression de satisfaction l'accord
criminel a aussi acquitté deux tchadiens
mais condamné deux autres intermédiaires
locaux à des peines moindres les six
Français eux sont repartis à la maison
d'arrêt de nedjamena
descriptible sans dire un mot comme
sonné par un verdict que beaucoup
estiment
nous trouvons en direct de jamena Mori
Guibert alors Amaury bonsoir beaucoup de
rumeurs circulent après ce verdict on
parle même de rapatriement qu'est-ce qui
va se passer concrètement maintenant
oui le scénario Françoise qui va très
certainement s'imposer c'est un retour
très rapide en France sous la forme d'un
transfèrement de prisonniers c'est
l'option choisi a priori par les
autorités françaises et tchadiennes les
avocats français de l'Arche de Zoé
comptent beaucoup sur ce retour en
France même si leurs clients seront
toujours prisonniers pour casser ce
jugement de la justice tchadienne car
ils estiment qu'il y a énormément de
vices de procédure à l'instruction et
durant ce procès qui aboutit à ce
verdict plutôt sévère un verdict il faut
bien le rater aussi qui vient apaiser un
petit peu l'opinion tchadienne qui avait
été très irritée par cette affaire de
l'Arche de Zoé
Castellane
des docteurs Philippe Van vinkelberg une
messe était célébrée cet après-midi par
le curé Guy Gilbert qui voulait ainsi
marquer sa solidarité avec le médecin à
Castellane comme à Mourmelon où habite
l'épouse d'un autre militant de l'Arche
de Zoé le verdict a été accueilli avec
consternation Loïc de la Mornay et
Matthias Barrois
elle s'y attendait mais ça n'empêche pas
les larmes et la colère vous savez
8 ans parce qu'il a soigné vous vous
êtes médecin infirmière vous allez faire
de l'humanitaire à n'importe quel moment
vous vous pouvez vous retrouver à la
place de Philippe c'est ça la justice
tchadienne elle est belle la présidente
du comité de soutien tente de
réconforter l'épouse du médecin
maintenant il va rentrer maintenant
c'est fait il va rentrer Metz banderole
de soutien le village de Castellane
n'accepte pas la décision de justice
oubliant sans doute un peu vite les
conditions rocambolesques dans
lesquelles l'association a agi une
association reconnue ce soir coupable de
tentatives d'enlèvement d'enfant amour
melon l'épouse du logisticien de l'Arche
de Zoé tente de relativiser la
condamnation
par rapport à ce qu'on nous avait laissé
sous-entendre alors que c'était dix ans
je dirais que voilà on a gagné deux ans
par rapport à ce qui était entre
guillemets prévu comme tous les proches
des condamnés elle espère une
extradition rapide vers la France
et avec nous en direct justement
Christine Péligat alors bonsoir madame
et merci d'avoir accepté de témoigner
dans ces circonstances difficiles la
peine évidemment est lourde 8 ans c'est
un choc
oui bien sûr que comme je disais on
s'attendait plutôt à 10 ans donc
oui bien sûr ça reste ça reste un choc
on peut pas le nier maintenant huit ans
pour un procès qui n'a été qu'une
mascarade pour pour avoir pour des
hommes qui ont
étant médecin sapeur-pompiers professeur
qui n'allait que dans un seul but sauver
des vies oui 8 ans c'est énorme mais je
rappelle que ce procès est une pure
mascarade est-ce que vous pensez qu'ils
pourront être transférés rapidement vers
les prisons françaises que vous avez eu
des indications des autorités françaises
à ce sujet
alors on a l'espoir bien sûr de d'un
transfert assez rapide surtout si on
tient compte de leur état de santé avec
cette grève de la faim les conditions il
est clair que il serait sage de les
rapatrier rapidement et puis bon après
je pense que nous avocats vont faire le
nécessaire pour voir ce qui peut être
fait et bien sûr que huit ans c'est pas
huit ans de travaux forcés donc il
faudra trouver communier cette peine en
quelque chose de beaucoup plus adapté
mais bon nous gardons espoir merci
d'avoir témoigné ce soir pour nous
madame Péligat retour en France du
rescapé de l'attaque qui a causé la mort
de quatre membres d'une même famille en
Mauritanie lundi le père de famille a
été conduit à l'hôpital il doit Herriot
de Lyon son frère ses deux fils et un de
leurs amis ont été tués dans le
guet-apens qui aurait été perpétré par
un groupe terroriste affilié à Al-Qaïda
Karim komassi
il a laissé derrière lui la Mauritanie
seuls et grièvement blessé François
tollé a retrouvé cet après-midi sa femme
et sa fille comme lui endeuillé il a été
transporté au service de chirurgie
orthopédique de l'hôpital de Lyon reste
retour pour ce charentais chez lui au
village on l'avait vu préparer son
expédition
il faisait ça réglo au point de vue
assurance au point de vue nourriture au
point de vue au point de vue de gasoil
enfin c'est un organisateur
très très ordonnée pendant ce temps en
Mauritanie les enquêteurs auraient
identifié deux des trois tireurs ils ont
abandonné ce véhicule avant de prendre
la fuite deux jeunes mauritaniens
membres présumés d'un réseau salafiste
proche d'Al-Qaïda
ils auraient reçu l'aide logistique d'un
troisième homme déjà condamné pour son
appartenance à un groupe terroriste tous
ont été filmés en juillet dernier à la
sortie du tribunal de Nouakchott tous
suspectés d'appartenir à la mouvance
islamiste mais libérée faute de preuves
embarrassé les autorités mauritaniennes
mènent l'enquête tous azimuts
aidez-moi les autorités et le peuple
mauritanien dans leur ensemble la chasse
à l'homme a commencé au Sénégal où les
deux hommes se seraient enfuis mais
aussi au Mali et dans le nord de la
Mauritanie des zones déjà visées par la
branche d'al-qaïdao Maghreb la France a
décidé de revoir ses conseils aux
voyageurs même position pour la
direction du rallye Dakar qui se rendra
demain à Nouakchott et puis on se valait
deux femmes membres de Médecins sans
frontières une infirmière Gentine un
médecin espagnol ont été enlevé dans le
nord du pays c'est dans cette région que
notre confrère guanogo il avait été
retenu en otage pendant 8 jours MSF a
décidé d'évacuer et son personnel
expatrié dans cette région du Portland
où les enlèvements sont devenus monnaie
courante
en Égypte le président français Nicolas
Sarkozy et sa nouvelle amie Carla Bruni
ont visité la Vallée des Rois à Louxor
main dans la main le couple est descendu
dans plusieurs tombeaux des pharaons y
compris celui de Toutankhamon et de ses
petits premiers exceptionnellement
ouvert pour eux suivi par une troupe
impressionnante de photographes ils sont
ensuite allés pique-niquer à bord d'une
fenouque sur le Nil accompagnée par l'un
des fils de Nicolas Sarkozy et la mère
de Carla Bruni à gauche on s'interroge
sur le financement de ces vacances
privées et sur la mise à disposition
d'un avion appartenant à l'industriel
Vincent Bolloré l'Élysée n'a pas
souhaité commenter
s'est installé dans l'Est de la France
neige et surtout pluie verglaçante ont
provoqué des accidents en série un homme
de 46 ans est mort dans sa voiture
encastré sous un camion et plusieurs
trains ont été retardés par le gel sur
les caténaires à s'en fiche
ment la combinaison est imparable sur
l'autoroute A6 plus fine sur ce gelée et
sur la route la moindre manœuvre devient
périlleuse avec le verglas la voiture a
glissée elle a pas réussi à la maîtriser
et elle a taper dans le premier acte de
sécurité à la traversée l'autoroute et
on a fini dans le sur le bas-côté dans
le rail de l'autre rail de sécurité le
plus souvent plus de peur que de mal
mais plus au nord en Bourgogne un
carambolage entre un camion et une
quinzaine de voitures à faire un mort
l'autoroute a été fermée une bonne
partie de la matinée
sur le réseau secondaire les sales ont
fait ce qu'elles ont pu mais des
dizaines de voitures ont terminé dans le
fossé aucun blessé grave n'est à
déplorer en ville le verglas immobiliser
les bus une bonne partie de la matinée
Dijon Besançon mais aussi Nancy personne
n'est informé alors l'impatience gagne
c'est honteux
c'est rien
à Dijon au réveil les premiers pas sont
difficiles un bon centimètre de verglas
alors chacun fait comme il peut
tu sens le trottoir oui devant chez moi
devant ma porte oui avec quoi avec du
sel de mer sur le réseau ferré câble et
catenaires ont gelé une bonne partie du
réseau nord-est a été retardée pour
cette nuit des risques de verglas sont à
prévoir
un retard à la SNCF était dû en revanche
à des actes de malveillance le trafic
des TGV entre Paris et Marseille a été
perturbé par des incendies sur des
câbles de signalisation une enquête de
gendarmerie est ouverte plusieurs
incidents du même genre se sont produits
sur d'autres lignes notamment sur le TGV
Nord la SNCF ne fait pour l'instant
aucun lien entre ces actions mais lors
de la grève des cheminots plusieurs
lignes TGV avaient fait l'objet d'action
coordonnées de sabotage dénoncé par la
direction et ces images sont signées
Grégory Vasseur justement la réforme des
régimes spéciaux de retraite sera
effective dès le 1er décembre 2012 la
durée de cotisation pour les salariés de
la SNCF de la RATP d'EDF de GDF passera
à 40 ans en 2016 à 41 ans les décrets
d'applications devraient être publiés
avant le 15 janvier explication Valérie
Lerouge et Christian Laurent
les réunions à la SNCF ou EDF ne sont
pas terminés qu'importe les décrets
alignant les régimes spéciaux sur ceux
de la fonction publique seront publiés
d'ici 15 jours la mobilisation de
l'automne n'y a rien fait les cheminots
gaziers ou agents de la RATP passeront
bien de 37 ans et demi à 40 ans de
cotisation 2012 mais le décret va plus
loin 41 ans en 2016 pour tout le monde
problème ce nouvel allongement était
supposé être discuté l'année prochaine
pour les syndicats le gouvernement va
trop vite il y a un rendez-vous en 2008
sur l'ensemble des régimes et c'est là
que la décision sera prise et c'est pour
ça que je m'inscris en faux quand on
indique aujourd'hui que les régimes
spéciaux de retraite vont cotiser 41 ans
en 2016 personne sait de quoi demain
sera fait la loi Fillon de 2003 prévoit
en effet de tout remettre sur la table
avant le mois de juin prochain les
syndicats entendent alors mobilisés tous
les salariés du public comme du privé
nous vous parlions hier dans l'eau de
foie gras potentiellement contaminé
vendus par la marque Montfort foie gras
au torchon authentique 430 grammes nous
vous donnions la référence du code barre
qui est toujours inscrit sur l'écran et
bien le groupe coopératif qui est
fabriqué Camille en place un numéro de
téléphone qui sera ouvert 7 jours sur 7
de 7h30 notez le bien c'est le 01 40 45
42 46 vous retrouverez cette information
sur le site www.france2.fr aujourd'hui
dans beaucoup de magasins de jouets ou
de cadeaux les services après vente
étaient largement sollicités par des
parents parfois débordés trans
électriques défectueux ou taille de
vêtements inadaptés reportage romain
Messi et Dominique bonnet
une grande bande bleue entre au milieu
du cadre
des cadeaux défectueux qui ne
fonctionnent pas l'appareil photo marche
pas bloqué les piles bloquées donc voilà
rapporte et des clients venus très
nombreux avec l'espoir de les échanger
dans ce grand magasin le nombre de
cadeaux défectueux est une information
confidentielle une certitude au service
après-vente on a prévu du personnel en
renfort on a plutôt une tendance à voir
plus 30% d'activité sur le mois sur les
semaines qui viennent
ceux qui se sont risqués à offrir des
vêtements n'ont pas toujours fait le
choix gagnant que j'ai offert à mon mari
dans ce magasin de jouets 1% de cadeaux
seulement serait défectueux mais les
parents reviennent les bras chargés pour
d'autres raisons
qu'est-ce qu'ils n'ont pas bien ces
cadeaux
parce que c'est des jeux de société que
elles sont l'univers c'est les chevaux
une valse des cadeaux qui devrait durer
une quinzaine de jours merci
et à Londres aujourd'hui c'était le
début des soldes devant les grands
magasins une foule nombreuse attendez
l'ouverture des portes et vous voyez
comme ici dans cette chaîne selfrid sont
ruées dès l'entrée et c'est vrai qu'il
faut s'armer de patience parce
qu'ensuite il faut quand même passer à
la caisse on a donné dit les pluies
torrentiels ont ravagé le centre de Java
les inondations ont provoqué des
glissements de terrain qui auraient tué
plus de 80 personnes les routes sont
coupées et de nombreuses maisons ont été
emportées
l'Indonésie qui comme les autres pays de
la région frappés par le tsunami il y a
trois ans peine à se reconstruire les
dons venus du monde entier ont été
abondants parfois trop même mais depuis
l'urgence a laissé la place au
développement état des lieux
explications avec Zinédine Boudaoud et
Damien Louvet
10000 bougies allumées sur la plage de
Patong dans la baie de Phuket l'hommage
rendu aux victimes du tsunami par leurs
proches et les rescapés thaïlandais et
occidentaux
c'était il y a trois ans sur une plage
toute proche une vague énorme engloutie
tout sur son passage
220000 morts au moins dans 12 pays
d'Asie
l'élan de générosité et sans précédent
dans le monde entier cette cause très
médiatisée a généré en France une aide
de 337 millions d'euros des pouvoirs
publics et 323 millions des particuliers
une manne examinée de près par la Cour
des comptes Georges capdebos qui a
épluché la comptabilité de Médecins sans
frontières la Croix-Rouge et bien
d'autres encore
nous avons fait des critiques dans un
certain nombre de cas nous avons signalé
un certain nombre de doubles emplois de
dépenses
inutiles de dépenses qui me
correspondait pas la vérification
de dérapage mais trois ans après un
tiers des dons on a toujours pas été
dépensés mettre 500 frontières avait par
exemple reçu 10 millions d'euros
beaucoup trop pour une ONG spécialiste
de l'urgence quand on s'est aperçu qu'on
pourrait pas dépenser tout ça cet argent
on a demandé aux gens explicitement si
nous autorisés à utiliser ces fonds
ailleurs pour d'autres problèmes moins
médiatisés moins visibles ce qu'ils ont
accepté à 98%. pour le développement en
revanche l'argent n'est pas trop
abondant les programmes de
reconstruction et d'éducation comme ceux
du Secours populaire par exemple ont
besoin de fonds et de temps aussi
les conséquences justement de ce
dénuement des populations pour survivre
certains rescapés vont jusqu'à vendre
leurs organes un rein trop preneur
jusqu'à 1000 euros et c'est un véritable
trafic qui s'est installé notamment en
Inde reportage Arnaud Miguet et Fabrice
Lemay
tsunami Naga en français le quartier du
tsunami c'est ici que les autorités ont
relogé les familles de pêcheurs qui ont
tout perdu il y a trois ans des oeuvres
ils vivent avec moins de 40 euros par
mois et sont devenus les victimes d'un
trafic sordide la vente d'organe c'est
le cas de soundary 35 ans elle a vendu
son rein il y a un an pour pouvoir
nourrir sa famille
on était terriblement endettés on a dû
emprunter beaucoup d'argent et on ne
pouvait plus payer alors pour sauver
l'honneur de la famille j'ai vendu mon
rein on m'a dit que ça rembourserait
toutes nos dettes on l'appelle
pour son rein et cette longue cicatrice
soundary a gagné 1000 euros soit deux
ans de revenus le marchand d'organe qui
s'est occupé de la faire opérer il y a
un an dans cet hôpital en a gagné lui
dix fois plus
la vente d'organe est bien illégale en
Inde mais des intermédiaires et des
médecins véreux profitent d'une
incroyable demande pour exploiter la
misère des victimes du tsunami
issus une grève coûte 25 fois moins cher
qu'aux États-Unis Chennai capitale
médical du pays a désormais la
réputation de capital du commerce
d'organe ce que déplore ce spécialiste
des gens prennent cela parfois comme une
évidence que nous fournissons des
organes venant de personnes vivantes je
leur explique à chaque fois que nous ne
faisons pas ce genre de transaction avec
des donneurs
il y a bien eu quelques arrestations des
fermetures d'établissements médicaux
mais le trafic continue cette ONG a
recensé pas moins de 34 personnes depuis
deux ans qui ont vendu leurs reins
surtout des femmes au même donnant le
texte pas de souffrir autant
contrairement aux femmes c'est pour cela
qu'elle vendent leurs reins et pour les
intermédiaires c'est plus facile de les
trouver elles sont à la maison plus
vulnérables
mourir plutôt que donner un de mes reins
je ne peux plus rester au soleil je ne
peux plus rien faire à la maison je suis
malade
soundary se souviendra de ce 26 décembre
2004 ce jour-là la vague du tsunami a
tout emporté la cicatrice n'est pas
prête de se refermer
en France les inégalités se creusent
face au logement selon une enquête de
Lindsay les ménages les plus pauvres et
consacre de plus en plus d'argent
jusqu'à 25% de leurs dépenses en
revanche pour des ménages les plus aisés
le poids du logement s'établit autour de
11%, il y a 30 ans se loger 12% du
budget de tous les Français et pour
permettre à certaines familles d'accéder
à la propriété les HLM mettent en vente
une partie de leur parc 140 000
logements sociaux seront disponibles à
la vente une façon de dégager des moyens
supplémentaires pour construire de
nouveaux logements sociaux portrait
d'une famille au Plessis-Robinson qui va
devenir propriétaire Jean-François
fieret et Chloé Leconte
F4 de 80 mètres carrés au
Plessis-Robinson dans les Hauts-de-Seine
prix moyen 240000 euros les gens Ivano
eux ont fait une affaire nous on l'a
acheté 160000 euros 160000 euros 30%
moins cher le couple en fait pu racheté
son hlm il louait 550 euros il rembourse
désormais 1000 euros par mois pendant 15
ans un tiers du budget de la famille le
maximum sans avoir à se serrer la
ceinture le financement était calculé
avec les HLM qui ont accordé des prêts
avantages
ce sont les conditions avantageuses des
HLM et sans ça vous pensez que vous
auriez pu acheter ou pas pas ici pas
aussi proche de Paris il y a un an tous
les appartements du lotissement ont été
proposés à la vente si locataire surdit
son dit oui les autres ne présentaient
pas les garanties financières
suffisantes
ça va nous permettre peut-être dans un
premier temps pas de nous assurer une
retraite
et puis dans un second temps permettent
de léguer un patrimoine à nos enfants
aussi croire l'office HLM lui reste
copropriétaire de l'immeuble et le gars
rend des nouveaux acquéreurs si par
suite des incidents de la vie veuvage
divorce etc un des deux salaires ne
rentre plus donc la personne ne peut
plus rembourser quoi c'est prêt l'Office
se substitue l'Office reprend la
propriété de l'appartement et garde la
personne qui retrouve un statut de
locataire dans ces murs les fonds
dégagés doivent servir à la construction
de logement neufs dans les
Hauts-de-Seine par exemple la vente de
3000 appartements financera 4000
constructions nouvelles
à Lille c'est l'hébergement des Roms qui
posent problème à la préfecture à
réquisitionner de nouvelles places mais
c'est insuffisant pour répondre à la
demande voyez ce reportage de Elsa Palo
et Dominique mas
ils arrivent régulièrement par petits
groupes sérum sont à la recherche d'un
toit pour ce soir mais dans cette
auberge de jeunesse réquisitionnée par
la préfecture la situation est devenue
quasiment incontrôlable ici c'est la
police qui gère et qui refoule les
nouveaux arrivants
ils vous ont dit de faire quoi la police
car les associations ont jeté l'éponge
elles acceptaient de gérer 60 personnes
ici il y en a plus de 100 malgré tout
Emmaüs livre encore des repas mais dans
le plus grand désarroi je vais même plus
l'énergie de la colère parce que je dois
dire que
ça fait un an que je connaissait de
travailler sur la problématique Rome et
je n'ai aucun sens dans mon travail car
la situation s'est considérablement
détériorée ces derniers jours plus de
600 hommes dans le département et
beaucoup sont désormais à la rue après
l'évacuation il y a une semaine d'un
campement à Lille puis ce fut l'incendie
d'un hangar abritant une trentaine de
personnes un accident qui a coûté la vie
à une jeune femme handicapée désormais
ce qui reste sans hébergement vivent
donc dans des caravanes à moitié
abandonnés
il fait froid les bébés les enfants le
matin quand ils partent à l'école ils
ont froid c'est une catastrophe
face à cette situation de crise le maire
de Lille parle d'un curry de l'État je
ne comprends pas que les tanne remplisse
pas ses missions et surtout ne
répartissent pas l'ensemble des efforts
sur l'ensemble de la métropole si chacun
prenait un peu sa part nous arriverions
à passer cette période et à régler le
problème justement la préfecture déclare
ce soir réfléchir à une répartition des
hébergements dans d'autres communes pour
soulager l'île en attendant ils seront
encore une centaine à dormir ce soir
dans l'auberge de jeunesse
aux Etats-Unis au zoo de San Francisco
un visiteur a été tué par un tigre qui
aurait sauté par-dessus les grilles de
son enclos deux autres personnes ont été
blessées l'animal a été abattu ses
accidents sont cependant rarissimes
explication Nathalie sa pena et Marie
crew
des policiers en armes des grands moyens
aux autres San Francisco un tigre s'est
échappé à la nuit tombée il a tué un
jeune homme avant de s'attaquer à deux
visiteurs attablis à la terrasse d'un
café
les policiers se sont approchés le tigre
les a repérés et ses diriger vers eux
c'est à ce moment-là qu'ils ont tiré
l'animal a été tué les deux rescapés
griffés et mordus sur tout le corps ont
été hospitalisés dans un état grave il
semble que l'animal une tigresse de 160
kg est réussi à sauter par-dessus la
barrière de sécurité et les douves un
bon de plusieurs mètres à peine croyable
je ne comprends pas un tigre ne doit pas
être capable de sauter ainsi
et comme celle-ci haute comme un homme
qui son capable de faire des bons de 6
mètres ici au cirque Pinder 53 fauves
jamais un animal ne s'était échappé
c'est impossible qu'aucun ne sort déjà
parce qu'ils ont pas de prise et aucune
possibilité d'accroche et j'ai un
système qui leur empêche de passer des
gens ils sont trop lourds pour pouvoir
avoir la possibilité de sauter des
barrières physiques régulièrement
inspectées par les services de l'État
mais aussi un personnel qui connaît bien
les tigres
si j'ai un animal qui sort pour quelques
raisons qui soient déjà il va m'écouter
parce qu'il a le contact avec moi et
parce qu'il m'obéit après c'est sûr
qu'il faut rester très vigilant ça
n'arrive pas aussi parce que déjà j'ai
du personnel qui travaille
continuellement avec moi aujourd'hui 20
000 tigres vivent en captivité 6 fois
plus que les 3500 encore dans la nature
le cheval et non seulement la plus belle
conquête de l'homme mais aussi souvent
le meilleur ami de ses enfants les
centres équestres sont de plus en plus
fréquentés par les jeunes et surtout par
les filles reportage dans le Val-d'Oise
Florence bouquillat et Matthieu Niven
Globes
endre quatre ans et demi deux mois de
pratique d'équitation derrière lui
quelques chutes à son actif et un mental
d'acier
je suis tombée beaucoup de fautes
l'équitation un sport de jeune la moitié
des 550
000 licenciés de la Fédération française
d'équitation à moins de 21 ans c'est
aussi un sport de filles 75% des
cavaliers sont des cavalières la plus
noble conquête de l'homme attire donc
peu les garçons peut-être à cause de
l'éventualité d'une chute ce dont
Nicolas vient de faire l'expérience
ça va Nicolas
lui croit savoir pourquoi les garçons
n'aiment pas mon terrassage
la plupart des champions de France du
monde sont des hommes donc je vois pas
ce qui pourrait être pour les filles
pour les sites hein l'équitation est un
sport difficile d'accès et souvent cher
à la campagne c'est un loisir plus
accessible mais toujours onéreux surtout
quand on a deux enfants passionnés de
chevaux
sur un an c'est à peu près entre 2000 au
lieu de 2000 euros quand même mais une
passion même coûteuse peut aussi
déboucher sur une perspective
professionnelle comme pour Clémentine 18
ans qui vient d'obtenir son CAP de
palefrenier soigneur je venais aider aux
écuries je venais défaire les soins et
ça c'est vraiment devenu plus en plus
c'était vraiment devenu quelque chose de
vraiment passionnant et j'ai voulu
apprendre en France les activités
Castres destinées au public génère
environ 20 000 emplois
la Slovénie ancienne état de l'ex
Yougoslavie et qui occupera la
présidence de l'Union européenne au 1er
janvier est aussi une nouvelle
destination touristique très prisée il
faut dire que les paysages et les
équipements sont exceptionnels vous
voyez ce reportage de Jérôme Bernin et
Christian Leroux
c'est l'une des perles des montagnes
Slovènes la légende veut que Dieu ait
donné il y a des siècles ce lac aux
habitants de la région parce qu'ils
étaient humbles et travailleurs ils
l'ont appelé Boeing cela signifie cadeau
de Dieu toutes les montagnes ont leur
légende celle de Slovénie ne font pas
exceptions mais ici on ne fait pas que
se raconter des histoires on aime
l'action le ski c'est le sport national
et ça se voit
des dizaines de stations parsem ce tout
petit pays grand comme trois
départements français les Alpes viennent
s'éteindre ici bienvenue à Gran
chicagora l'une des plus fameuses
stations slovène une épreuve de Coupe du
Monde se déroule chaque année mais il y
en a pour tous les niveaux
et voici justement un débutant Chris
Moore est anglais comme la moitié des
touristes ici et sur la piste
forcément ça se voit
pour Chris son épouse et leurs trois
enfants venir en Slovénie était une
évidence rien qu'au niveau des tarifs
1200 euros par personne absolument tout
compris
sur Internet parce qu'on m'avait
recommandé cette région et en effet pour
nos cinq c'était moitié moins cher que
ce que nous avions vu à l'origine une
semaine de ski aux États-Unis
et pour ce prix pas le temps de
s'ennuyer même la nuit
si jusqu'à 22 heures des casinos partout
et même
des concerts de pop Loven pour les plus
jeunes
mais la priorité reste avant tout le
sport escalade canyoning ski de fond
raquette
un peu plus bas nous voici à Bled son
château son île sont des corps de conte
de fées
il s'appelle triglave ça veut dire trois
têtes de 1864 mètres ici on pratique
plutôt la randonnée les balades dans un
cadre de carte postale la montagne
slovène gagne chaque année 10% de
visiteurs supplémentaires mais reste
encore très méconnu des Français à peine
5% des touristes pendant la présidente
slovène de l'Union européenne les
dirigeants de toute l'Europe vont eux
aussi avoir la chance de découvrir les
merveilles de la montagne ici une
conférence des ministres des Affaires
étrangères se déroulera d'ailleurs
autour de ce lac ce sera au printemps
prochain
Laurent Gerra revient sur scène au
Palais des Congrès pour la suite de son
spectacle consacré à la télévision sa
vie son œuvre celle de la télévision
bien sûr mais cette fois il le dit avec
des chansons reportages de Abdel Mostefa
et Frédéric Delarue
deux ans et demi que Laurent Gerra
flingue la télé sur scène n'est plutôt
que de terminer sa tournée marathon dans
la discrétion il a choisi de le faire
avec tambour et trompette grâce à
l'orchestre d'un ami
lui donner mon orchestre tout simplement
le Big Band là c'est et il est c'est du
vrai musical avec ça qu'ils ont le
talent à fleuriste
plein de femmes
et maintenant chez moi il y a Carla un
brindacu est toujours les mêmes cibles
ajustées avec l'aide de Jean-Jacques
Peroni co-auteur des textes
il est vilaine il est Vilaine
département préféré de Bertrand
delanoë-haut il est vilaine
méchanceté
à la grosse berthaie
bien c'est que tout le monde en prend
plein
plein la gueule comme on dit
avec un tel orchestre le final est
forcément musical hommage au montant
traîné et autres Bécos référence du
quasi-carotenaire Laurent Gerra
alors on vient de dire à l'instant 49
vous allez fêter vos 40 ans sur scène là
je me fais un petit plaisir mais oui
alors justement pour la suite de votre
spectacle sur la télévision vous êtes
entouré de musique c'était pour arrondir
les angles ou au contraire
ça faisait longtemps que je voulais
tourner avec un big band c'est vrai que
j'avais vu le big bang avec Guy Marchand
comme il le dit et c'était aussi parce
que le public me demandait souvent
pourquoi vous chantez pas plus dans le
spectacle alors attention c'est pas que
des chansons sont des parodies et puis
surtout ça ne se fait plus d'avoir des
formations comme ça derrière il y a 19
musiciens je m'amuse beaucoup beaucoup
je suis très très
grande on est porté on est porté mais
surtout on a l'impression que ça fait un
an qu'on tourne tellement on a sur la
même longueur d'onde moi c'est le genre
de musique que j'aime ce que dit Guy
marchandrai moi j'aime le music-hall
j'aime j'aime la vraie belle musique
j'aime l'orchestre j'aime ce côté là de
du et puis vous revenez un peu à vos
premières amours parce que l'imitation
justement en chanson c'est un genre que
vous aviez un peu abandonné j'ai
commencé quand j'avais 5 ans
pour le concert de la fanfare de mon
village et puis là je suis avec un Big
Bang oui c'est oui j'ai toujours aimé
chanter
aussi que vous retrouviez comme ça les
les personnages absolument et puis ça me
permet d'en faire plus c'est à dire que
j'ai pu en faire des nouveaux que je
pouvais pas faire juste avec un piano je
peux faire le brassage je peux faire
Bernard Lavilliers je fais Serge Lama et
puis tout est orchestré c'est à dire
même la marseillais je l'ai fait
accélérer pour Sarkozy ah oui parce
qu'ils veulent parce que ça va vite mais
on retrouve les
classiques la grande saillie martial
c'est ce qui ouvre le spectacle
Céline Dion un nouveau Johnny avec tous
les cuivres qui se lèvent parce que
voilà quand on a des cuivres il faut que
ça se lève il faut que ça pète donc il y
a un noir c'est noir avec Johnny de ne
des nouveaux textes un nouveau Sarkozy
forcément vous avez introduit d'ailleurs
si je puis dire
les nouvelles actualités du président de
la République absolument ça je vais en
parler de l'Égypte
parce que souvent vous parlez beaucoup
de choses disons un peu l'Est qui à la
télévision
pourquoi on en prendrait pas ça très
fort quand même j'ai remarqué vous dites
que c'est votre meilleur spectacle
celui-là donc c'est celui pour lequel je
prends le plus de plaisir parce que être
avec des musiciens c'est extraordinaire
c'est rare d'ailleurs on fait qu'une
quinzaine de dates exceptionnelles je me
suis fait plaisir là pour mon
anniversaire on l'a déjà joué un peu en
province et je j'ai un réel plaisir
parce que c'est c'est très joyeux c'est
très festif d'avoir un bel orchestre et
vous changez comme ça
le soir en fonction je sais pas de la
qualité de ce qui s'est passé dans la
journée de ce que vous avez vu
aujourd'hui au journal télévisé de
France 2 vous ne ratez jamais surtout
quand c'est vous parce que je suis en
vacances mais là je travaille donc je le
fais toujours avec vous on va faire un
tour puis chanter avec moi je viendrais
et donc vous adaptez en actualité on va
revenir sur
l'écrani régulièrement pour pour parler
de des nouveautés à intégrer c'est cette
chance que j'ai d'ailleurs depuis deux
ans c'est de pouvoir faire évoluer le
spectacle et de m'amuser qu'est-ce que
vous allez faire après parce que le 31
c'est c'est fini
ça ressemble un peu au bled
ça ressemble un peu votre
bah oui je vais profiter un petit peu je
vais écrire un petit jean-lucilite qui
va sortir et puis je crois que je me je
m'éclate tellement avec cette orchestre
que je vais quand même faire quelques
dates supplémentaires j'aurais très
envie on se refait pas ma bonne dame
merci en tout cas nous parler de votre
spectacle avant de terminer ce journal
je vous en rappelle le principal titre 8
ans de travaux forcés pour les six
Français de l'Arche de Zoé le procureur
général avait requis une peine de 7 à 11
ans la cour criminelle n'a pas souhaité
les différencier les familles espèrent
en transfert rapide des condamnés vers
la France que Paris devrait demander aux
autorités de tchadienne dans les plus
brefs délais c'est la fin de ce journal
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi tout de
suite la météo présentée par Laurent
Romejko 20h50 une comédie intitulé super
granny.com je vous souhaite une très
bonne soirée sur France 2 et je vous
donne rendez-vous demain à 20h bonsoir
faut en continu c'est aussi sur France 2
point fr